-Rachel Zegler,
welcome to our show.
We are big fans of yours
here at the show,
so thank you so much
for coming on.
I appreciate this.
-Thank you for having me.
I'm so -- I can't even.
This is crazy.
-Alright, good, good.
I'm excited.
I have things I want
to ask about you.
One is your name -- Rachel.
-Yes.
-You got this -- You got your
name from someone very famous.
And am I right?
-You are correct.
I was named after
Rachel Green from "Friends."
-Okay, good. Alright.
That is real?
-That is real.
That is a real fact.
And everybody --
Nobody ever believes me
because they think
that there's no way
I'm young enough
to be named after "Friends."
But --
-No, you were.
-But I am, yeah.
My mom -- They were
going to name me Catherine,
but my older sister's
Jacqueline, and they thought
that might be too confusing
for babies to figure out.
-Yeah. Catherine and Jacqueline.
Yeah.
-Yeah. And, so, yeah,
my mom loved the way it sounded
on "Friends"
for Jennifer Aniston,
and then that was my name.
-I mean, that's a perfect
person to be named --
We love -- Who doesn't love
Jennifer Aniston or Rachel?
-I love Jennifer.
-You could have been
named after the hairstyle.
-I could have been Ross.
-You could have been Ross.
-Who knows?
Yeah, alright.
-All right, why not, right?
-Ross Zegler's got a good name
to it, as well.
-Yeah, right?
-Well, if you want to have
a brother...
I want to talk to you
about this,
because I know you're a big --
You're a big Swiftie.
-Yes.
-And you were at the...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, how cool are you?
-She looks very sad,
but that was just
because I had food poisoning.
-No.
-I did.
-You did not.
You still went to the show.
-Oh, I would not have --
I sold my kidney to be there.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-You love her that much?
-I love her so much.
-Back-in-the-day Swiftie?
-Yeah.
From self-titled album,
which we're still waiting
for the re-record of.
[ Cheers and applause ]
See? I found my people
in the audience.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But do you -- Are you
one of those people
at the concerts that yell out,
"Oh, the next song
is going to be this or..."
-Oh, I knew the set list,
I know the callbacks,
and I was waiting
for the secret songs.
-Secret songs.
-Yeah.
-My best friend, Brenna,
had gone in Atlanta,
before the MetLife show,
and I went to MetLife Night 1.
And she said --
-Whoo!
-Thank you.
And she said to my older sister,
Jacqueline,
who I took to the show
with me --
She was like, "Jacqueline,
if they play 'Getaway Car'
or 'Maroon,'
she's on crisis watch."
Not only did she play
"Getaway Car,"
she also played "Maroon."
I was having a mental breakdown
in the audience
at MetLife Stadium.
-I love it.
-Yeah.
And then Ice Spice came out.
And I kept making the joke --
-That's right.
-Exactly.
-I remember that.
-Yeah.
-That was a big deal.
-I was making a joke all night
to the girls behind me.
Wherever they are,
they can attest to it.
I kept making the joke that
Ice Spice was going to come out,
not knowing anything about
that actually happening,
and then it happened.
-Wow. So you should
play the lottery that night.
-Yeah.
-Anything you did came true.
-My Swiftie manifestation
says "Reputation TV" is coming.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-Thank you.
-Right now, let's talk
about "Hunger Games," okay?
"The Ballad of Songbirds --"
Let's focus.
The "Ballad of Songbirds
and Snakes."
-Yes.
-By the way, your character,
Lucy Gray,
sings a lot in the film.
-Yes, she does.
-Which is great.
Which you did live on set.
-I did, yeah.
-You can do it.
You know how to do it.
I mean, I was reading somewhere,
there was, like, inspirations
of Dolly Parton in there.
-Yeah, yeah.
Well, it's -- She's a very --
She's a country, folksy singer.
And, so, Suzanne Collins,
who wrote the book --
she used to be
a country-music deejay.
So she had this, like --
-Oh!
-Yeah. And it's like
she has such
a deep knowledge
of that whole world,
which I really didn't know
too much about.
-I didn't know
she was a country deejay.
-I didn't either.
-That's fascinating.
-Yeah. And so she's obsessed
with Dolly Parton, Patsy Cline,
and then we kind of
based her voice off of that.
-How cool.
-Yeah.
-Well, the soundtrack --
it comes out this Friday,
as well, with you
are featured on it.
-Yeah.
-And Olivia Rodrigo
is featured on the album.
-Yeah.
So everyone's
talking about this.
-Yeah.
-It's already got over
a million streams already.
It's just crushing.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-And you accidentally
started a rumor,
and I thought tonight
would be the perfect night
for you to clear up this rumor.
-It's time to address it.
Oh, my goodness.
Yeah, I accidentally
started a rumor
that Nicki Minaj
was on the album
for "The Hunger Games:
The Ballad
of Songbirds and Snakes."
-That is not true.
-It's not true. She's not.
She's releasing her album
on Friday, I believe.
But it was one of those things
where there's a character
named Barb Azure in the movie.
And the actress who plays
Barb Azure
has a great sense of humor.
Her name is Honor Gillies.
She's so fantastic.
And posted a video
of Nicki Minaj saying,
"Calling all Barbs"
when she got cast.
And her character plays
the stand-up bass in the movie.
So, obviously, I commented,
"Slapping that super bass,"
as you would.
-Yeah.
-Now, the Barbs got me good.
They were screen-shotting
those comments,
posting them
all over social media,
being like,
"What is mother doing?
They are very, very, very
dedicated and amazing.
I am a Barb.
I love Nicki.
-Yeah.
-But she's not on the album.
But she started playing into it.
She posted a TikTok
with "The Hanging Tree" song,
saying like, "I have something
coming out November 17th."
Like, she knew what
she was doing.
I had no idea what I was doing.
-No idea what she was doing.
No, no. You were just being you
and you go, "I didn't know.
I'd even start this rumor."
-And I didn't know if she
was on the soundtrack,
so I was just
kind of like, "Okay."
-And she's not.
-Okay, good.
I'm glad you said it.
-Just me.
-Yeah. No, good. I'm glad.
It's you and Olivia Rodrigo.
-Yeah.
-We're happy.
-Okay, yeah, we're good.
-Thanks.
-Do we set -- How do we set up
the movie "Hunger Games"?
This is pre-Katniss.
-Set 64 years in the past.
It's been 10 years
since the districts
and The Capitol
have, like, gone to war.
And the Hunger Games have been
going on for 10 years.
-It's a giant,
giant, giant movie.
And I would suggest go see it
in IMAX because it's just a lot.
-And we did film it for IMAX.
It's the craziest experience.
-Enjoy it.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Rachel Zegler
in "The Hunger Games:
The Ballad of Songbirds
and Snakes."
Take a look.
-♪ This world, it's dark ♪
♪ This world, it's scary ♪
♪ I've taken some,
and so no wonder I'm weary ♪
♪ It's why ♪
♪ I need you ♪
♪ You're as pure as
the driven snow ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
♪♪
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Rachel Zegler!
"The Hunger Games:
The Ballad of
Songbirds and Snakes"
is in theaters
and IMAX this Friday.
Hi to Fiona?
-Hi to Fiona.
-Hi, Fiona!
We'll be right back
with Tariq Trotter, everybody.
Stick around.